زمن الحرق زمن الخيارات الصعبه
يفكر دانيال طويلا حاله كثيرين بمالاته
بعد ان قطع نصف الطريق في دراسته الجامعيه
ان كنت في اوكرانيا فامامك طريقان اما
خطوط القتال او حدود البلاد وبينهما واقع
حرب لا ضمانات فيها يعني لا استطيع مساعده
اصدقائي الذين يقاتلون على الجبهه ما
افعله هو القيام بدورك مواطن مدني في
حمايه دولته لدانيا الرفاق يتقاسمون
الهواجس ذاتها ولكل رايه فيما ينبغي فعله
الى ان تضع الحرب اوزارها
[موسيقى]
شنو
في قاعات التدريس بقيه تواصل تعبيد طريق
المستقبل لكنه بات مختلطا برائحه الحرب
جزء مما يعملون عليه هنا تطوير تقنيات
وانظمه يقولون انها ستفيد جيش بلادهم في
حربها
في غرف اخرى اختار اخرون الحضور عن بعد
وعدم المخاطره مع احتمال القصف المستمر
حتى على العاصمه
تدير اولينا هذه الكليه وتراها خطا جبهه
اخر لا ينبغي التخلي عنه تقول ان الحرب
ارخت بظلالها هنا بعد ان اخذت طلبه
ومعلمين الى الجبهات وابقت اخرين
العديد من الطلاب والاساتذه يقاتلون في
الجبهه انتقلنا للتعليم عن بعد والتواصل
مع الطلاب اصبح اقل بكثير ولكن لدينا امل
بعوده الوضع لطبيعته واعاده المحاضرات
المباشره في اوكرانيا نحو 800 جامعه وكليه
يدرس فيها اكثر من مليون طالب وكانت وجهه
لنحو 70 الف طالب اجنبي قبل الحرب بين خط
المعارك على طول جبهات البلاد وبوابات
السفر بعيدا عن الحرب يحاول الشباب في
اوكرانيا خط معادله مستقبلهم معادله
البقاء او الرحيل بعد ان غيرت الحرب
الحسبات وقلبتها
عدنان الجزيره كيف